His name is Chris Hadfield.
The book is and astronauts guide to life
on earth.
The book is in here that that's me.
I never forget.
I never remember.
Rather turn my laptop off.
You,
uh,
you were in space for 166 days.
Mazing.
That's insane.
It's,
it's when I sit on my dock and watch the
space station go over,
uh,
it's really hard to rationalize cause I
know I was up there and I can remember
all the details,
but to try and link in life on earth
with,
uh,
with seeing that spotlight go across the
horizon,
it's still,
I haven't got sorted out of my head how
to connect it.
Is that the longest of persons ever been
up there?
There was a Russian guy named Valerie
poliakoff.
State of 14 months straight.
$400,
whatever that is.
Stays long time.
Wow.
Yeah.
No,
I'm nowhere near the record.
That's still increased.
One hundred 66 days is an incredible
amount of time to be detached from
gravity and floating around in space.
What is the effect on your body?
A big effects short term?
Huge.
Your body doesn't have to lift the blood
up to your head when you're weightless,
right?
So your whole cardiovascular system
changes all the nice little mechanisms
that squeeze the balloon that is your
body to get the blood up to your head.
They stopped working.
Your heart gets smaller,
you start losing your skeleton.
Your balance system completely shuts
down.
I mean it has no stimulus from gravity
anymore.
So you become totally visually based.
So when you come home,
it's brutal.
Building all those things back up again.
Um,
and most of them you feel,
I mean,
you lose the callouses on the bottom of
your feet.
It's kind of disgusting cause you're
sure your feet are like a snake up
there.
Over the bottom of your feet are
shedding because you never used the
bottom of your feet and you build up
calluses on the top because you're
always tucking your feet underneath
things.
So when you come back,
you've even have to grow the calluses
back in the bottom of your feet.
And the thing that takes the longest is
your skeleton.
I lost about eight percent of the bone
across my hips and butt.
It's grown back and within about a year
of landing all hopefully be back to
normal one year.
It takes one year for your body to fully
recover.
It took about four months before I could
run normally again where my body would
get the blood out of my feet and pump it
properly back up to my head,
about four months,
which is almost as long as I was up in
this trip.
But uh,
yeah,
the bone takes the longest,
but it's a,
it's automatic,
which is interesting.
My body got osteoporosis and it's
reversing osteoporosis using some
internal stimulus that we don't even
understand.
So it makes a pretty good medical study
for everybody.
I would imagine.
So how long is.
How long do you have to be in space
before your body loses so much?
Massive skeleton and the first time you
take a leak in space,
your urine is full of calcium and
minerals.
We do urine samples all the time and
your body,
we don't even know why.
We don't know what sensors in the body
recognize that you're weightless or why
we would even have those sensors,
but your body starts to shed your
skeleton right away and we've,
we can almost beat it now through a
heavy exercise.
We have a bunch of equipment on board,
a resistive exercise and treadmill and
bicycle and stuff.
Um,
and with that we can almost beat it.
But across my hips and my upper femur,
we haven't been able to load that area
up.
Right?
You always lift symmetrically on
treadmill.
He always run nice and symmetrically so
you don't get all the banging transverse
loads that you need to make your body
keep the bones dense there.
So how much of it can you preserve by
using exercise?
The rest of my body was fine.
In fact,
I increased muscle mass,
decreased fat a little bit.
My bones were at the same density.
The only place we haven't solved yet is,
is just the hip cradle.
And I think with another iteration or
two of our exercise equipment,
we'll get that solved and then I'm going
to go to Mars.
Wow.
So now,
how long are you when you're doing
exercise to try to build up what
percentage of your day to doing two
hours a day?
Every day?
We do one hour of cardiovascular and one
hour of resistive every single day.
Seven days a week for the whole half a
year.
The up there that we've determined
that's the best trade off between
getting useful work done,
you know,
because it's a big multinational
laboratory and keeping your body
healthy.
So we we commit about two hours a day.
Did they,
when they first started going up there,
did they not do anything?
No.
We've tried a bunch of different things.
The Russians even try to suit.
They call a penguin suit,
which is like a set of coveralls,
tight fitting coveralls that's full of
elastics so that every time you bend
your elbow or move your twist,
your body or something,
you're fighting the resistance of the
suit because they thought then you could
sort of get it for free,
but you need to demand it.
You need to actually heavily force your
body to exercise and if you do that and
then you can stay in shape,
but we've,
you know,
we started out with resistive exercise
device and that it was the improved I
read and now we're on a red,
which is the advanced resistive exercise
device as we've learned,
you know,
how to make it better so that we,
uh,
we can return to earth healthy or you
know,
when we go to the moon,
but more importantly,
what we going to.
Maurice Cook takes about half a year to
get there.
Well,
we're,
this is one of the problems we need to
solve the Mars is really that next level
trip,
right?
Because there's no coming back.
It's,
it's like several levels above where we
are now.
Station is in orbit around us.
The space station.
It's been up there 13 years now with
people on board.
Um,
but it's like a sailing up and down the
coast within sight of land.
You know,
we haven't had it across the body of
water even to go to the moon as far as
habitation goes.
So right now we're just sailing up and
down the coast of the world figuring out
how to beat osteoporosis.
How did the radiation,
the psychology of it,
the what to make the whole lot of,
how do you make a toilet that works at
the closed environmental system.
Got to invent all those things.
Then I think we'll go to the moon
because it's the next.
It's only three days away and then we
can do how to use resources that are
there.
How do you generate power?
How do you navigate,
how do you do all that?
And then once we got that sorted out,
then I think we'll go further.
But it's still,
you know,
a lot of years away.
What,
what are the big hazards,
the big hazards or radiation from space
micro meteors?
Yup.
And what else?
A psychological.
How do you keep people sane and it's not
so bad in the space station because
we're close to the world.
There's only like a two second delay
talking on the radio so you can have a
normal conversation.
Just a little pause.
But,
uh,
as soon as you start going to maurice,
within a couple of weeks,
you will never have another conversation
with earth and normal and again,
everything's got so much leg that she'll
just have like recorded video messages
back and forth.
And so the psych impact of that is going
to be high and the earth will shrink to
just another star within a couple of
weeks,
you know,
and that,
those people will become Martians in
mind.
They will no longer be from Earth.
They will see themselves as separate.
When I was on the space station the
second time,
one of the other crew members,
her name is sue Holmes,
uh,
she and I were talking,
we'd known each other since test pilot
school.
And in passing a throwaway thing,
she didn't even think she was saying.
She said,
hey,
you know,
Earth said that we're supposed to do
this next.
And in my mind,
not heard,
Earth said,
I heard those words come out of her
mouth.
And it was like she has in her mind,
completely split off from the other 7
billion people.
There's her crew and earth is one
singular identifiable entity on the
other side and that was a real bell
ringer to me of what it's going to be
like to go to Maurice.
Those people are going to be a
completely discrete unit of people and
there'll be Martians.
They won't be earthlinks pretty quick.
Their heads and how do you deal with
that?
How do we plan for that and it's still a
long ways in the future,
but it's one of the many things we need
to sort out before we.
Because as you say,
once you get the engines going fast
enough that you're.
You're headed for Mars.
You can't just turn around.
There's no coming back.
That's it.
Well,
I mean the Apollo Thirteen,
right?
They lost an engine on the way to the
moon that coasted all the way to the
moon and they just used like a ball on
the end of a string.
They just went around the moon with the
gravity of the moon to sling them back
at Earth again.
So if something failed on the way to
Mars,
you could do the same thing,
but it would take a year.
So you know,
no problem can normally last a year to
get resolved.
So pretty much,
yeah,
you gotTa have all the problems solved
before you head that way.
And what about like sustainable
resources?
Like as far as like food and things like
that,
did they have to when they have to terra
form when they get to Mars and we don't
know.
We're trying to figure all that out.
I'm a really interesting discovery about
three weeks ago.
Curiosity,
that big rover that,
that is driving around on Mars right now
has some pretty good equipment on it and
it discovered just in the last few weeks
that in every cubic foot of dirt on
Mars,
there's a quart of water.
So there's oceans of water.
I mean the topsoil is full of water on
Mars.
So that's really promising for when we
get there.
Um,
because water is hydrogen and oxygen and
oxygen to breathe hydrogen and oxygen
mix fuel,
hydrogen,
oxygen makes water.
So that's a huge resource.
The moon,
there's water there,
but it's really rare,
so that's a big discovery for us
eventually being able to go there,
but you know,
we need a power source.
The Sun's a long ways away and it's
dusty on Mars.
You can't just,
you can't have a solar powered
bulldozer,
you know,
you need a power source and we need how
do you navigate and there's just a
whole,
how do you build a perfect closed loop
environmental system so that you don't
have a constant losses and because the
space station we only.
I think it's about 92 percent of our
water we reclaim,
but we constantly need that little
trickle from earth of new water because
it's not perfect.
There's,
there's a whole.
There's a lot of stuff we did when don't
even know what we don't know yet and
that's I think why will we'll start a
lot of that out on the moon.
Before we launched a Mars,
to me,
watching the footage of the rover and
the images that had sent back was almost
surreal.
It didn't seem real.
It's hard for me to wrap my head around
the idea that they sent a robot to
another planet.
It's roaming around taking pictures and
sending them back and we're looking at
it.
Yeah,
it's phenomenal.
It's incredible that we could do that
and and the way that,
you know,
Maurice has has just the wrong
atmosphere.
It's not thick enough to use a parachute
in,
but it's not thin enough that you can
ignore it and just and just slow down
and land with a rocket.
You know,
it's,
it's not good for landing.
The Earth's atmosphere is nice and
thick.
You can come down under a parachute and
the moon has none,
so you can just like the Apollo guys,
you can just land on your rocket plume.
Maurice,
you're kind of stuck in the middle,
so you need a complex landing system and
curiosity.
The way they came up with a solution to
that was just phenomenal.
The big Arrow break through the
atmosphere and then that sequence of
miracles and the retro rockets and the
extendable bridal and everything.
It is amazing that that worked and huge
Kudos to the jpl guys and everybody who
came up with it,
that and the stuff it's teaching us
about how planets work and what is what
is the past and the future for that
planet Mars and therefore gives us a lot
better understanding of what's normal
and what,
what,
what can we can expect on earth.
A huge Kudos to those people.
Indeed.
I mean,
they did an amazing,
amazing thing and just one of those,
in my opinion,
one of those paradigm shifting moments
where when we're back here on earth and
we're watching those images,
you're like,
wow,
they can do this now I'm,
I'm an astronaut,
an astronaut and you know,
I've been in space twice and I gathered
my family around to watch that thing
happened because it's so.
It is right on the edge of what we can
just barely do.
It's such a brave thing to do and such a
capable probe,
a capable extension of assault to put
down on the surface and it's teaching us
about Mars.
Did you ever pay any attention to the
face on Mars or any of that?
Crazy.
That's all fun.
And,
and you know,
there's,
there's faces all over.
I mean,
just lay on your back and look at the
clouds.
There's faces everywhere,
right?
That's sure.
We naturally look for faces,
especially in weird shadowy images.
Those images were mean.
There were some really unique things.
There's a rock near my house that's a
square rock and when I have a friend who
believes in a lot of conspiracy theories
and he believes in the face on Mars and
a lot of different stuff,
and I said,
I'm going to show you something,
man.
Come over here.
I go,
look at that rock.
Do you think anybody made that rock?
That rock has just made.
That's just a rock amongst the pile of
rocks.
It's big and it's kind of square.
Not Perfectly Square,
but if you looked at a blurry picture of
it that was taken from space,
you would swear this is the building
block for a paramed.
Obviously,
she's clearly made by an intelligent
species.
Same one that built the pyramids.
Yeah,
I know.
It's,
it's always easier to believe something
than it is to understand it.
Yeah.
The fascinating thing about the face on
Mars is not that it looks like a face on
Mars.
It's the idea that Mars at one point in
time actually could have sustained some
form of life.
In fact,
definitely did.
It had an atmosphere that was livable at
one point in time.
They really.
There could've been some kind of life.
Maybe it was just like microbes or
plants or might still is the biggest
volcano in the solar system,
so it has heat and it has all this
water,
but we've just found now for sure and
heat and water on earth always means
life to me and just look under your sink
and so on.
On Mars.
Maybe there's a fossil record of it.
Maybe there's even something still
primitive stuff living somewhere in the
rock we don't know,
but we haven't found any yet,
but if we can find that on Mars and we
know this life on earth and there's life
everywhere and that would be a pretty
important thing to figure out or the
possibility that life actually started
on Mars and some sort of an impact from
an asteroid panspermia senate hurling
towards birth.
I'm not sure that's a logical
conclusion.
You know,
if,
if life can start somewhere,
then it can start in two places.
Right.
And so it doesn't have to miraculously
be Panspermia from one planet to another
if it formed on Mars than and there's
life on earth and it's a more logical
conclusion to think that it just formed
in two places I think.
Do you,
when you,
when you sit in that space station and
you're floating above earth much as you
were saying that your colleague started
referring to Earth as a separate
individual entity and you guys were
separate from Earth.
Did you look out when you're looking at
the vastness of everything?
I mean it's just everything.
And Dee dee did feel like earth was in a
neighborhood more like,
you know what I mean?
That we weren't isolated.
That where it's so silly.
The thing is so big.
Did you feel like more connected to the
rest of the universe in any sort of a
way?
Joe And you're in the side of the
spaceship and you look at the world,
you're looking at it through the
windows.
And I came back,
it was so funny.
I came back from my first space flight
and was sitting in the living room with
my wife Halena and we were watching star
trek and they show that scene with Sulu
and whoever upfront and there's the,
there were in the standard orbit,
Mr Sulo and there's the curve of the
earth underneath.
And I remember going,
that's it.
That's exactly what
it looks like.
They got that right.
They guessed right in 1968 or whatever
it was.
Because when you're inside the
spaceship,
it looks like that.
The difference is when you go outside
and then um,
you are,
it's like the difference between sitting
in your living room,
looking outside and hanging on a cliff
or you know,
hanging on half dome or somewhere where
it's an entirely different perspective
even though it may look at the same
thing.
Being outside is a,
is so immersive.
The world is no longer nicely underneath
you,
like dark,
like Sulu,
but it is,
it is this huge hanging,
a spinning mass next to you and the
universe is what's around you and you
are,
you are part of it.
You're suspended in it.
It's that we aren't used to have in the
universe,
under our feet,
on all around us and,
and feeling that you're in it not just
sort of blow it,
looking up at it and that is really
different and that's when you really see
that the world is just in the
neighborhood and that it is a ball with
the moon being a ball in the son's over
there.
And if we go up there,
that's Maurice.
You really get that feeling when you're
out on a space walk.
I've heard several astronauts talk about
that feeling and that that moment when
they are outside of the spacecraft and
looking at the universe itself and
saying that it changed them forever.
Uh,
it gave me a profound respect and also
I'm,
I don't even know.
I mean nobody knows the answer,
right?
Big Bang and all the rest of it and all
the,
all the belief systems around the world
and how everybody deals with all that.
And I sure don't know the answer to
that,
but when you look at the world,
it's,
it's really hard to convince yourself
that it's random.
Just looking at it,
it's like how can that possibly be?
But then again,
if you look a little further out,
there's,
you know,
how could maurice be random and how
could all the other planets,
how could Saturn,
the way it looks to be just a random
event.
And,
and,
uh,
the unlimited number of stars that are
out there and the planets we're seeing
around other stars directly.
I don't know how to resolve it.
In my mind,
I didn't,
uh,
find the meaning of it all.
Like being on a spacewalk,
if anything,
it just deepened my dumb foundedness at
the,
uh,
at the immensity of it in our tiny
little part of it.
Yeah.
I've often thought that questions
pondering questions like the randomness
of the universe or the,
just the reality that we know about
subatomic particles and the idea of the
universe being this fractal thing and
impossible and never ending.
I think it's almost like walking up to a
mountain and going,
yeah,
I could see how that could be picked up,
but you can't really pick it up
yourself.
So you're just like,
man,
I guess.
I guess it could be random.
I don't know what I don't understand.
I don't even know what the fuck random
means.
The idea of random seems the universe
itself seems to be this incredibly
complex thing has not just laws but very
clear directions that things move into.
It constantly is complexifying from the
big bang till now.
And the idea of black holes,
the eating matter and creating a
singularity and that possibly these new,
these new astrophysicists and string
theorist guys are saying that they think
that inside every black home may in fact
be a completely different universe.
You know on the top of the space
station,
we have a experiment put there by a
Nobel prize winning physicist named Sam
Ting and it's from cern,
from the big particle accelerator that's
under.
I'm Switzerland and France to their baby
and it's up there.
It's a huge magnet and what it's doing
is collecting subatomic particles of the
universe and it's.
It's got layer after layer of detector
so I can try and figure out what they
all are as they come ripping through and
it's collected trillions and trillions
of them.
It's been up there for the last couple
of years and the reason is we don't know
what the universe is made of.
We can only account for five percent of
the universe with the known particles
that we have five.
We don't know what 95 percent of the
universities even made of.
And so we call it dark energy and dark
matter,
and we're trying to indirectly prove
that those exist based on the
proportions of the subatomic particles
were collecting up in the top of the
space station and it's a decade,
a long project,
and they released the first layer of the
results back in the spring and it's
starting to look like,
like maybe some of the theories are
correct,
but we're,
you know,
we've talked as if were were
conclusively brilliant and we understand
everything.
I mean we're still calling things dark
matter and dark energy.
We have no idea.
I'm just trying to figure it out.
That's another word for magic.
It is indeed.
It's another word for,
I don't know.
Well,
it's,
we,
we are most certainly the smartest and
the most informed human beings that have
ever existed as far as we know,
the two of us.
No,
no.
Denying me 100 percent.
I'm not an idiot.
But as far as like humans that have ever
lived where the the most informed the
most technologically capable,
but much like when we look back at the
renaissance era,
or we'll look back at Galileo being in
prison because he dared question the
idea that the earth wasn't the center of
the universe.
We're going to make fun of us some day.
They're going to make fun of us like
these dummies.
They didn't know what Clark was glue on.
Plasma was.
They had to use a particle accelerator
to prove that the Higgs Boson existed.
Yeah,
I agree.
We're going to look at the space shuttle
and go.
What were they thinking?
I'm at station wagon.
I think it's just so ridiculous.
Like a DC three now.
You know.
That's one thing I really wanted to
bring up with you.
You know,
you,
you had to take one of those up there.
You have to take some sort of a
spaceship up there.
What is the feeling like of good?
Did you have to get an,
a Russian one?
My first two flights were on shuttles.
I flew Atlantis and then endeavor and
then my third flight I was left seat,
so sorta like the pilot of the Soyuz,
so I flown them.
Wow.
So you flew when the space shuttle was
in operation and you flew the Russian
version of the space shuttle.
What's the difference?
The shuttle is is so much more capable.
It is the most capable flying machine
humans have ever built.
Unbelievable.
And three quarters of everybody who's
ever flown in space flew on the shuttle.
It was the first great lifter.
It's purpose was to take a huge spy
satellite up.
This was the conception of the sixties
and early seventies.
Take the best technology.
60 spy satellite launch out of
Vandenberg.
Go straight north,
go halfway around the world,
take pictures of the hot spots of the
world,
come back again,
and then use the wings to be able to go
sort of sideways and side slip because
the world's turned underneath you and
come back and land again after one
orbit.
That's why we had wings on the shuttle
was so that we could carry this huge
telescope and they weren't automated
back then,
so we needed a crew to be able to
operate the telescope.
That's why the payload bay was the size
that it was and why the shuttle could
lift the amount that it could lift.
It was to meet all those requirements.
That all immediately stopped being the
reason for the space shuttle to exist,
but the design was already set.
What that gave us though was a vehicle
that could carry,
gosh,
40 or 50,000
pounds up in a payload bay that's a size
of a city bus and then bring it back and
land it gently on a runway and carry a
crew up to seven.
So is like a space station all on its
own and amazingly capable vehicle.
Amazingly complex too.
And when things are amazingly complex,
they're really expensive and hard to
operate safely and we lost two crews,
you know,
as a result of the complexity of it.
The Soyuz is designed to take three
people and a tiny bit of gear up to the
space station doc.
Stay there for half a year or longer as
their lifeboat and then at the end of
time get back in and come back home
again.
That's the uses purpose and it does that
really well,
but it's tiny and very purpose built.
The two of them are magnificent
vehicles,
but built for way different purposes and
both very carefully evolved to do what
they do.
Um,
you know,
exquisitely well.
Um,
and I,
I'm lucky to have flown on both.
That sounds so incredible.
Yeah.
What is the g force field like when you
take an off from the,
the launchpad you go straight up.
Of course you have to get above the air.
Um,
if,
if you want to stay in orbit,
you got to go five miles a second.
If you're going a little slower,
it's,
it's sort of like throwing something
sideways.
It gravity pulls it down.
But if you can throw it sideways at five
miles a second,
then gravity will still pull it down.
But the earth curves away underneath it.
If it's going fast enough,
you know,
it's like,
goes over the horizon before it falls.
So that's how we stay at orbit is we go
five miles a second,
but you can't go five miles second in
the air,
the frictions just too high.
So the rocket ships take you straight up
to get you above the air.
And that takes about two minutes going
straight up and in 45 seconds here
through the speed of sound,
straight up and accelerating.
And in 70 seconds you're through the
altitude and speed of the concord
accelerating,
straight up.
And after two minutes here,
about 160,000
feet and six times the speed of sound,
but you're above almost all of the air.
And then your first stage falls off.
So inside it's this,
it's this incredibly powerful push in
your back like a dragster.
But like one that's,
that's gone off the road,
the vibration of,
of uh,
pushing through the air,
that's,
it's a,
it's like a tuning fork kind of
vibration.
This enormous powerful jaws of a dog
kind of ride straight up.
But then after two minutes,
the solids are the,
the stage that got you above the air,
all out of fuel.
It explodes off because you don't want
to carry all that dead weight with you
anymore.
And then you use the remaining engines
for the next six minutes or six and a
half to accelerate out horizontal
basically to five miles a second.
And uh,
and so for the last six minutes,
it's like a long liquid drive,
heavy,
steady pushing someone with their fist
in your back,
pushing you faster and faster and
faster,
smoother ride because you're above the
ear.
And after just under nine minutes,
like eight,
eight,
45 or so,
you're exactly the right place,
the right direction,
and the right speed,
the engine shut off.
And you're in space and you're
weightless.
So it's nine minutes.
Yep.
It's 8:42
on the shuttle and just under nine,
like 8:55
for the Soyuz.
What's the maximum g force you
experienced during that?
Uh,
the shuttles about three g.
and in fact,
when you hit three g with the throttle
start coming back,
because it was only built for about
three and a half g.
So three times your normal weights.
If he weighed 200 pounds,
you weigh 600 pounds in there.
The so use is about four or four and a
half.
So if you're 200 pounds a year up
around,
you know,
eight,
900 pounds.
I got a ride with the blue angels and
whether those f eighteens ones,
I was nfat pilot for a lot of years.
Those are incredible.
That's a great airplane.
You got to fly those.
Yeah.
What's the most jeezy pulled in the
moment?
One of those things.
If you take an f 18 and you grabbed the
stick and you snap it into your lap,
um,
you aren't actually connected to
anything except a computer.
It's little sensors.
It's fly by wire.
So it says wow,
he wants to turn right now.
And so then it moves all the control
surfaces of the airplane,
but it doesn't want to break the wings
off.
So it will limit you.
It's,
it's the airplane limits,
the amount of Ge that it can pull and
it'll give you about eight g about age.
That's all it will give you because
otherwise you could structurally damaged
the airplane.
So there was a paddle,
you could actually,
if you are going to hit the ground,
you could hit this paddle that would
override the g control system and snap
it in your lap and just give you
whatever the aerodynamics would give
you.
We've had people pull 12 g but uh,
but the Soyuz,
if you come into the atmosphere the
wrong way,
can pull 20 or 22 g on the way home,
which is just,
just wicked.
And that happened once in the Russian
experience live that you're lying down
when you're in fat.
And like when you flew with the Blue
Angels,
you're sitting upright.
So when you pull back,
it pushes the g,
the blood down to your feet.
So the real limitation is how much of
that can you stand before you can't.
You can't stay awake for your blackout
in a Soyuz we're actually laying on her
back so the blood doesn't drain out of
your head.
It just gets kind of pushed to the back
of your body.
So therefore you can survive it.
It won't block you out,
it doesn't damage you.
It's,
it's sorta like a prolonged car crash,
you know,
people pull 20 g in a car crash,
but it's instantaneous if you fall into
the atmosphere the wrong way in a Soyuz.
Then as you hit the thick atmosphere,
it's almost like crashing into something
super high gp for maybe 30 seconds and
then then you come through that gp can
slow down and it's survivable.
But I wouldn't want to write it.
That feeling must be just incredible.
What,
what are the thoughts that are going
through your mind when you're,
when you're going that fast shooting up
in this space.
I,
uh,
it was funny.
You know,
I'm focusing on the job because there's
a million things that can fail and one
of the mantras of astronauts is there is
no problem so bad that you can't make it
worse.
So we think of it that all the time.
And so we,
we really are careful in the way up and
so a big part of you is involved with
that,
but another part of you is just,
is just loving the ride so much.
And I found after a while that my cheeks
were hurting and I was like,
why is my face hurt?
And I realized because this smile,
this big stupid smile on my face,
so much of my cheeks were cramping up
because it was so much of a thrill.
That's an amazing.
Yeah.
It was like heaven.
You know,
one one,
those two people on your shoulders,
one that's being all serious in one
that's yelling bad advice to you.
The one that's having a good time is
just going ahead.
I just love on the ride.
It is so much fun.
Guess that's a good time to do that,
right?
Because you're completely helpless.
Actually.
Joy.
Helpless
at all.
Yeah.
You're,
you're,
there's all sorts of stuff that you're
responsible for on the way up in the way
down.
And even in the is when you lying down.
Oh,
in the suite.
What do you have?
Full control panel and there's stuff you
have to do or you have to do as it's
happening.
Oh yeah.
What do you do?
Why,
why?
While you're flying,
if everything works perfectly,
we're just watching.
And,
and same in the shuttle.
We have very,
you know,
hopefully don't have to do anything,
but sometimes things don't go right and
then you got a bunch of things you can
do,
you know,
various shutdowns in a board,
certain people probably don't know,
but,
uh,
the shuttle as it launched up the east
coast of theu ,
s,
uh,
we kept abort landing runways all the
way up to coast.
You could land at Cherry point or can
land in New York,
you could land in Newfoundland or all
those places.
And so as you're ticket up the coast,
you're constantly going,
okay,
if we have a failure,
now we're going to abort this way.
We're going to turn around and land in
Bermuda.
We're going to land here,
we're going to land.
And you practice those like crazy.
Then you get to a certain point and then
you would land in North Africa or South
France or in Spain and all those
windows,
all those tick points,
all those,
uh,
thresholds.
You have to get your word.
That's what we're hyper aware of.
We're not,
we're not along for the ride.
Wow.
So while this is all going on,
you have these big giant smile and you
still are calculating.
Oh yeah.
You still going?
Okay.
If it screws up now I go here.
Oh yeah.
I run into my thumb down a long list of
all the various wickets that you're
jumping through.
Yeah.
You pay attention.
How much of the trip is automated?
How much of it is manual?
Uh,
we'd like it to be as automated as
possible because,
uh,
if it's,
if that means things are predictable and
things didn't break and for the vast
majority of shuttle flights.
And so he was flights,
it's automated,
but sometimes it's not.
I'm on the way up hill and we've had
engines fail or engine start to fail,
had to shut engines down and go to
backup or at least,
uh,
a reserve,
a configuration of the engines.
You get the launch.
Yeah.
During lunch that happened at a couple
of shots.
It happened on Apollo as well on the way
back to Earth.
Uh,
we've had serious problems with the
Soyuz where,
uh,
you have to take over and try and fly
manually or come in ballistically,
which means it loses its ability to
steer on the way home and you just start
spinning the vehicle and then it just
comes in like,
like a pure media,
right?
And you pull about eight or nine g on a
ballistic entry and that's,
uh,
that's,
that's pretty tough after six months of
weightlessness to suddenly,
if you're a 200 now a 1600 or 1700
pounds.
And that's,
that's,
that's pretty hard on the body.
Wow.
It's incredible the feeling that you
must have had when you actually stepped
onto ground again.
What was that like?
It's awful.
You're,
you're so nauseous and dizzy.
And,
and,
um,
the reason is of course,
a,
your vision is telling you one thing,
telling you where the horizon is,
where up is,
but your inner ear,
which normally when your eyes are
closed,
keeps you from falling over.
You know,
you can close your eyes and not fall
over.
That has forgotten completely what to do
with gravity because you've been
weightless first,
whatever,
five or six months.
So now you have this sudden great
violent disagreement between what your
eyes are saying and what your inner ear
is saying.
It's like if you spend 50 times and then
stop spinning and you stagger around,
so your body says,
oh,
there is something seriously wrong.
Why is his vision so wildly different
than his inner ear?
And for the last million years,
one of the probable cause is was you ate
something poisonous.
You ate some sort of neurotoxin or
something that is messing up your
internal systems and it might kill you.
So the first thing your body makes you
want to do is throw up because it's
trying to get rid of whatever it was you
just ate.
And then the next thing your body makes
me want to do is go lay down and go to
sleep.
Stopped it,
right?
It's trying to keep you alive.
So when you first get back from space,
your body's just screaming at you to
throw up and glide down.
But,
uh,
you know,
you got all this stuff to do and people
were there to meet you and um,
and you're trying to just ignore those
symptoms and,
and pay attention to what,
you know,
what's going on.
Is there a happiness along with that?
I mean,
is there a feeling of being home?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
all three of my flights and,
and if the flight went well and we work
hard enough that they almost always do,
there's a great sense of satisfaction
because we just,
it's like the final step in an extremely
complicated process where you have done
everything right or enough things right
that,
uh,
that you can,
you can like Kinda have that for the
rest of your life.
So there's a,
there's a tremendous feeling of,
of joy and pride and accomplishment.
And when you get back to Earth,
I have always been fascinated by space
and if you look up you can see the
lights here are covered with sudden I
like,
I like your lights stars good.
Um,
but what,
what drives me nuts is how little we
actually get to see of the stars because
of light pollution.
I was a at the big island and I went to
the Keck observatory.
Yep.
And there's the,
uh,
there's a station where the telescope is
and then below that at like 9,000
feet.
There's like this visitor station.
Have you been?
Uh,
I've been near there.
I put up at the top of a couple of the
mountains there to have a look at the
sky.
It's in incredible.
It's,
we,
I was,
when we were driving up there,
I was worried that it was too cloudy.
I was like,
oh,
this is going to be terrible,
you know,
we wanted to go and see the stars and we
picked a cloudy night,
but we drove through the clouds.
And then when you get above there and
you realize that the entire big island,
they have special diffused lighting to
make sure that they don't emit light
pollution.
The view is life changing.
It must be like one,
1000000th of what you experience on the
space station.
But for me it was a real life changing
moment.
I'll never forget it and I'll think
about it all the time.
Whenever I look at the stars,
I always think about that night in
Hawaii,
that's what it looks like,
but,
but even crazier,
there's a.
there's an image of it up there,
but even crazier when you're actually
experiencing and you could see the Milky
Way,
and I remember thinking,
God,
we have to figure out a way to stop
light pollution because I think just
that,
just being able to look up and see that
would change people's perceptions and
would probably make people way more
enthusiastic about space.
People know,
of course the vast majority of people
live in cities and the places that have
the worst light pollution of the city.
So I had a similar experience to yours
when I was in fat pilot.
I would get it up to high altitude.
I'm going on a cross country,
especially in the north,
put on the autopilot and it's shut off
every light in the cockpit and let my
eyes adjust.
And you're already up at 40,
45,000
feet and so there's almost no atmosphere
above you and you could see the texture
of space.
You can see the Milky Way.
You can see why it's called the Milky
Way.
I mean,
it's a,
it's a white,
gray,
white part of the sky,
you know,
and you don't need a telescope to see
it.
You can just see it with your eyes.
You don't need some special time lapse
photography.
So,
uh,
it,
it's both humbling and uh,
and really inspiring I think to see,
puts everything into perspective,
but I don't know,
even if you're trying to work on light
pollution,
people are indoor creatures and cities
and they have street lights and they
drive around in cars and I don't know
how you get people to notice the
universe around them.
I think it would help if they could just
see it start.
If you look up in Los Angeles,
ca,
what do you see?
You see a star.
I lived in Houston for a long time and
yeah,
I look at that.
I can see 18 stairs tonight.
It's a real clear night,
barely.
But when you're up there and the,
and the observatory and I'm sure when
you were at 40,000
feet in the jet,
it must have been amazing.
Yeah,
it's,
it,
uh,
it's not that much further away.
I mean,
uh,
the big island mountain is not all that
high,
but you just need one sometimes one
small step and you can see a whole new
thing.
Yeah.
I had some similar but not quite as
intense viewings in the mountains above
boulder,
Colorado.
So like at 8,500
feet up there,
it was beautiful too.
But I think that we forget that we're
really in space.
It's as stupid as that sounds really do
forget.
So I was going around the world and my
son who ran the social media for the
flight to a large degree,
send me a note saying,
Hey dad,
Mt.
Etna is erupting in southern Italy,
have a look of Mount Etna.
So I'm a good dad.
Took a picture of how Aetna,
but I'm seeing the superheated lava and
the smoke and the steam coming out of
the earth,
uh,
was a really,
especially when you're looking at the
world as a ball,
was a really clear reminder of the fact
that most of the planet is super heated
lava and magma and where it's so hot
that the rock is liquid and plastic
right then and we just live on this
little chilled crust like,
like the top of a porridge pot,
you know,
and we just live on this little thin bit
at the top that is crossed.
And when you tip it the other way around
and look up half of the atmosphere is in
the first three miles,
three miles,
you know,
think about why people go for a three
mile run.
You know,
that and half really the whole habitable
atmosphere is three miles above 15,000
feet.
It's hard to even live.
And we live in beats on this little bit
of cooled crust and this little sliver
of air.
And we think it's guaranteed.
We think we think we're invincible,
right?
And we think the whole universe is here
to serve us and we're like,
we're like bacteria in a corner,
you know,
just just found a little niche that will
support our life.
So much so that we're willing to almost
our entire system as far as energy is
based on burning thing.
Yeah.
Let's face it,
releasing few talk about a hundred years
from now looking back and going,
what were we thinking?
I mean,
Golly,
I mean you can see why a five gallon
pail of gasoline is an amazingly
enabling thing.
You can stick it in your car and drive
hundreds of miles,
you know,
and you can carry it in your hand and
it's fairly stable.
It's a very seductive fuel.
But at the same time it has such
consequences.
And when we look,
when we figure out the next energy
source,
when we look back,
hopefully in a couple of hundred
years we will go,
what were we thinking?
Oh,
crazy.
Yeah.
We see the.
It's really hard for people to change to
once once we have a pattern that we
follow,
it's very difficult,
especially if we found a way to make it
work for ourselves in spite of all the
pollution.
We still rock it that way.
In spite of all the stuff that we throw
into the ocean.
We still kind of happening basically on
a daily basis.
Well,
you can't.
Once you built a structure,
it's really hard to change of course,
and you can't just suddenly start.
Millions of people are killed,
millions of people just because you
decide to change energy sources.
It has to be gradual and we will be
weaned off fossil fuels,
but they got to get a lot more scarce
before we're going to bother just
because of its human nature.
Will.
The ultimate use of fossil fuels is a g
is a rocket.
I mean that's the ultimate display of
it.
Shooting into space with a giant plume
of fire behind you.
It's a brute force way.
I mean it.
We're burning dinosaurs to get this
space,
but it's so far.
It's the only way we figured out how so
far it's the only way.
Now when you,
you think about like what's possible for
the future when they start talking about
all these different propulsion methods
that will someday be available.
What if any of them appear viable?
Yeah.
You're asking me to predict physics,
uh,
inventions of the future,
which,
Gosh,
I wish I could do that.
I'd go,
I'd do it tomorrow.
I don't know,
uh,
to,
to me the obvious answer is,
uh,
every single molecule that exists,
every complex molecule and Adam was put
together in a blast furnace of a place
with almost unlimited heat and pressure,
which is the center of a son and it
stored that energy in every single atom
and molecule that exists.
And we have yet to find a good way to
get that energy back out.
But there is more energy and a pencil.
You know,
if you,
if you could truly get the energy that's
inside all of the molecules that are in
there,
there's,
there's so much energy stored there.
You know,
we have like wood that stored sunlight,
right?
And we by burning it,
we can release that stored solar power,
even nuclear,
but we haven't found a clean way to
release the energy to gives us nuclear
power.
We can do it,
but we're still,
you know,
we're kind of cave men about it and we
haven't got a clean way.
So I'm certain that at some point we
will figure out how to,
whether it will be cold fusion or,
or just fusion itself,
but if you read what they're doing in
the various laboratories around the
world,
even the experts think,
well,
we're probably years away
from,
from being able to contain fusion so
that it becomes a net positive power
source.
And,
but you know,
when the experts are saying it's 50
years until we can do it,
who knows?
Yeah.
There was a recent article in one of the
science magazines that the volume of
nuclear waste could be reduced by 90
percent that they've shown that they can
mix plutonium contaminated waste,
uh,
with blast furnace slag and turn it into
glass and it reduces its volume by 85 to
95 percent and effectively locks in the
radioactive plutonium creating a stable
end products.
I've always felt like,
I mean,
the,
the nuclear waste thing is a huge issue
obviously.
I mean,
they've done a lot of weird things like
dig holes in the ground and buried in
there.
And Nevada and you know,
and what's going on now in Fukushima is
very disturbing.
They're trying to figure out how to
contain it.
Sure.
Coming up with all these different ways,
but it's a fascinating thing about human
innovation.
If their backs are up against the wall,
those crazy monkeys figuring out a way
to fix things.
Yeah.
And it's just our nature and necessity
is the main mother and we need to.
Sometimes we don't think we have the
necessity.
And nuclear waste is a big problem with
fossil fuel waste is a huge problem as
well.
And neither of them are perfect.
Even solar energy has waste,
you know,
because of you have to build all the
solar panels and you have to collect all
the rare earth metals.
None of it's for free.
We have to find as best to trade off as
we can and,
uh,
and still be able to try and sustain as
good as standard of living for as many
people around the planet as possible.
And uh,
and we've done we,
I mean,
we feed more people now than we ever
have,
right?
But,
but how,
uh,
how do we do it in the future?
How do we get better at it?
I'm not sure he,
there's so many variables obviously.
And,
but I,
I'm,
I'm always very excited when I see
something like this that has like,
oh my faith in the crazy humans has been
restored like these,
these nuts have figured out a way to fix
an issue or at least reducing issue
significantly by as much as 90 plus
percent.
Um,
the,
the fossil fuel thing to me is a,
is a weird one because obviously I enjoy
it,
we use it,
it's so important for almost everything
we do,
but obviously this is going to create a
problem some day and there's no better
example for that for me than the
automobile pollution or pollution that
you get from jet airplanes,
uh,
on a daily basis.
How much it means there's a big impact
in the environment.
Every time the space shuttle gets
launched,
isn't it a,
well,
compared to everything else it's.
Well,
and of course space shuttle is retired,
but we only flew the special at 135
times.
I mean,
you couldn't even measure compared to
everything else,
the pollution that it injected,
if it had gotten to the point where it
was like Arab travel.
Yeah.
Well you wouldn't want,
you know,
thousands of those launch and everyday,
but that wasn't,
that wasn't a possibility.
It wasn't.
But it was going to do.
But compare it to just,
you know,
how we burn coal to generate electricity
and how we use to transport ourselves
around the,
uh,
you know,
there are 40,
what,
42,000
people a year killed just in car
crashes,
you know,
that is a,
it's a societal norm in the United
States.
We expect that.
We say that's okay.
It's all right to kill 42,000
people.
So we have the freedom to drive our cars
around wherever we want.
Kind of an interesting level of accepted
a disaster,
you know,
we just say that's okay.
And that's not,
that's not some global warming problem
that may manifest itself on our
children.
That's a guaranteed thing this year.
And uh,
and that's,
uh,
just an interesting thing to hold up the
mirror and look at yourself and say,
okay,
that's,
that's what we decide is alright,
who's also a matter of,
of a very statistically significant
number of years of your life that you
lose by living in a small filled
environment.
That's a fact.
Sure.
And we don't think about that because
you can survive and be healthy in New
York City,
you know,
you can go jogging down the streets of
Manhattan and you know,
drink spring water and think
everything's all groovy.
But the reality is if you're living in a
city and you're breathing in those fumes
on a daily basis,
it will reduce your life.
Period.
Yeah.
But,
but yeah,
I agree with you,
but none of us are lasting forever and
people live where they want to live for
all the reasons.
And only one of the variables is how
many years are you going to live there?
Right?
Would you rather live in the middle of
nowhere where the air is clean,
but there's no people to talk to or in
the theater is really bad.
Theater is always bad.
Let's be honest.
What's the best theater or even nearly
as good as the best movie.
It's not even close,
antiquated,
goofy art form.
I'm okay here.
I have to ask you about these guys.
Yep.
Aliens.
That little alien guy.
Sam,
when,
when you're up there,
when you're in space,
I mean,
do you ponder the possibility?
And is that something that you ever
wonder yourself?
Are there intelligent life forms out
there?
And if so,
do you think that they watch us?
Do you think they're aware of us?
You mentioned earlier that with Galileo
inventing the telescope,
uh,
he was tortured for pointing out that we
weren't the center of the universe and
I'm with every invention that's come
since then,
we've been able to prove more and more
conclusively just how far from the
center of the universe we are and also
how huge the university is.
And billions of years old and,
and more vast.
The numbers are so big,
they're,
they're incomprehensible both in numbers
of,
of stars and number of galaxies.
And within the last few years,
using the great-great-grandchildren of,
of Galileo's telescope,
we are seeing planets directly,
seeing planets around nearby stars.
And we've seen thousands of them.
So we've basically shown that every
single star has planets.
And so there's an unlimited number of
planets out there.
And so to think that with an unlimited
number of that,
we are the only life in the universe to
me is just a natural extension of
thinking that we're the center of the
universe.
You know,
it's an arrogance,
egotism thing was based on belief
instead of fact.
But it's also,
I think arrogant and egotistical to
think that were so fascinating and we're
so revelation area and,
and so special that somehow a weird big
black eyed monsters with no hair on
their bodies are sneaking around staring
at us because we are so special.
To me that's just.
I mean it's fun science fiction and it
makes for great entertainment,
but it's a,
it's not real.
Well.
I've heard that the archetype of the,
the doctor,
the alien with the large black eyes and
the,
you know,
the strange big head that what it may
very well come from is that the actual
birth experience for children the first
time the eyes are outside of the womb,
they don't have clear vision and they
see the bright light of the operating
room,
which is the first time they've ever
been exposed to something like that.
And it's an incredibly traumatic
experience.
They recognize the eyes,
which are enormous in front of the head,
the face with a white mask on it,
feature lists interesting.
And that this is most likely what the
archetype of the experience,
the,
uh,
the medical experiments that supposedly
go on with these aliens,
that,
that's the origin of it.
And it's,
well,
we have this very arrogant idea that
children don't remember things,
you know.
And it's been my point about
circumcision I,
I don't think circumcision is a good
idea.
I think it's ridiculous.
I think it's antiquated.
It's Jen genital torture.
And I think the justification is one of
them is that the baby doesn't remember
it.
And I'm always like,
how do you know the baby doesn't
remember just because they don't have a
point of reference or context.
It's very possible they remember it
well.
The scientific answer to the alien
abduction experience and these cold hard
medical examinations,
emotionless medical examinations may
very well just be the birthing process
or some of it will search both.
And then the,
you know,
the incredible feeling of helplessness
that they have is basically their body
doesn't move yet and that these intense
memories are burned deep,
deep,
deep into our consciousness.
I think it also just comes from a fear
of being alone and a fear of being
mortal.
And if we can somehow convince ourselves
that,
that neither of those two things are
true,
then it's a great comfort to folks and
to think that,
that there's other life out there.
And,
and it's,
it's,
uh,
it's holding us as super special and
it's been here before and it's going to
be back.
It's,
it's a nice seductive thought process to
go down.
So,
but there is there.
I mean,
we have left Earth,
we have 13 years ago this month,
we permanently started living on the
space station with the International
Space Station program.
And the Soviets had been there for
decades before on their space stations.
We have sent probes to every planet in
the solar system and got one going out
to Pluto right now.
And we're rovers on a couple different,
three different planets and moons in the
solar system.
Uh,
if aliens did show up,
I don't think their behavior would be
the one that is in the common science
fiction media,
you know,
it just doesn't make sense.
So,
so I,
uh,
I am convinced there's life in the
universe,
you know,
just starting the statistics of it.
It just makes sense.
It's,
it's just,
um,
it's just egotism to think that we're
that special.
But I think it's also just egotism to
think that we're so special that were
the object of great secretive
fascination by higher beings.
Well,
I think you're very humble and so you
look at us and say that it wouldn't be
that interesting,
but I say to you,
imagine if we found out that there was a
planet just outside of our solar system
where there were some people that were,
were there,
they were just like human beings,
but they will like human beings from the
13 hundreds.
Yeah.
They just hadn't figured anything out
yet.
We would be like,
holy shit,
they have guns.
They figured out the wheel that lighten
their city's on fire.
They're crazy.
They just haven't figured out mass
communication yet.
And most of them can't read.
I think we would be as a lot like us
right now.
It's just a lot like us right now.
We really haven't changed that much.
But I mean if we found some people just
from a thousand years ago,
a thousand years in our past,
we would be absolutely incredibly
fascinated.
I think if we found some being somewhere
that had harnessed the power of fire,
and if we went back 40,000
years ago,
I think we'd find it incredibly
fascinating.
So the stuff that we can do,
I don't buy it.
I think if I was an alien,
I would be so fascinated by these
freaks,
these pink monkeys with bank sticks and
the Internet and religions and all the
freak show stuff that we have down here
on earth.
I think we would be the most wonderful
freak show of all time.
I've often said that if there is,
if there is intelligent life in the
earth that I think are outside of earth,
I think that earth is probably the
Tiawana of outer space.
Which explains why all visitations come
in the middle of the night,
that they're just,
they're hammered and they want to see a
show.
They want to go see the freak show.
I think if I was an intelligent being,
I do not buy the idea what would be so
special about human beings?
Where do we start?
Okay.
There's a lot special about this crazy
species above all other species on this
planet.
There's 7 billion of them.
Okay.
They're like rats on a sinking ship.
They inhabit every little spot in the
ocean,
find a little floating thing.
Poking out of the ocean were some plants
are growing on it.
Boom is a whole whole sea of people live
in there.
You know,
go to Hawaii,
this little tiny spot.
It's a million people in Hawaii who were
crazy and I think I would look,
I think we got to go there and we got to
go to earth.
I think we would be probably one of the
most fascinating things to observe
because we're so incredibly advanced and
yet so contradictive so,
so hypocritical,
so ridiculous,
so easily led,
so easily tricked and fooled.
We have access to instant information,
but yet we choose to believe some of the
most ridiculous things of all time.
Yeah,
I,
I agree with you though that I find the
evidence of us context,
but aliens,
incredibly uncompelling and the people
that I talked to,
I,
I did a Scifi show called Joe Rogan
questions.
Everything where I met with a lot of
these Ufo guys and I felt like I was
talking to religious fanatics.
Yeah.
It's just like talking to a religious
fanatic.
It's just they feel like they're too
clever for the Koran,
so they fall for the blue book project.
Blue Book is their,
their Lord.
So two weeks ago a satire paper in
Canada published a thing about what I
did at a movie theater watching the
movie gravity and they said,
I heckled it and I've heard about that
and I farted to protest the movie.
You did all this stuff and got thrown
out of the theater.
That's really rude.
I thought it was very funny.
Right?
Read this article.
Thousands of people believed it and sent
notes and send it to their friends and
hey look,
hey,
look,
this is,
this must be the truth because I believe
it and that thinking is so easily
prevalent and dominates a lot of
populist conclusion making when in fact
it's not based on fact at all because
people want to believe stuff,
but they don't want to spend any time
actually doing the thinking or the
research about it.
And so,
uh,
you know,
that that's pervasive,
right across all cultures,
including what people think about,
you know,
alien abduction.
Yeah.
That was also a real problem with the
access to information right now.
So beautiful.
Anybody can get information at anytime
but it's not vetted.
So,
and there's also a lot of what they call
satire sites,
which are just not satire.
They just lie,
right?
I mean,
there's,
there's been,
there's this one national news something
or another website that people keep
constantly tweeting me stories from and
they just make up stories.
There was one about that,
uh,
I retweeted before I read where it came
from,
that Texas decided to use sexual
predators for medical experiments and
there's,
but there's just,
it's just a lie.
There's no,
it's like if you read the onion within
five minutes or five seconds,
you realize,
okay,
they're doing comedy.
This is funny business humorous,
they,
they're not being humorous,
just lying and they're calling it
satire.
When you see that attributed to you like
farting in a movie theater,
that's rude.
And I've read it and I,
I had it sent to me like,
this guy's an asshole.
Like he farted in the movie.
It made me laugh,
but the reaction to it made me laugh as
well.
It's just like,
come on people please,
we,
you know,
we are actually sell separate from the
one celled organisms.
We have brains and reason and experience
in logic and use it.
We're clearly still developing clearly.
Right?
I mean there's both and everybody.
This folks like you that have
experienced technology and innovation at
its very height,
the,
the highest highs,
you've actually gone out above the,
the actual atmosphere of our earth,
and you've experienced the amount of
technological sophistication that it
takes to pull something like that off.
But then there's other folks that are
barely there,
chimps with a language and they exist
amongst us because of this complex
society.
It makes it really for people to just
get by and breed and make more dumb
people.
It's so.
It's so easy.
Well,
so you've got to have that,
right?
Is this the Yin and the Yang of life?
Uh,
you know,
I think the real key to it is what does
everybody want to get out of it?
What do you want to get out of your life
and what do you,
what do you find is your own compulsion?
What,
what is it that that gives you the
satisfaction at the end of the day and
it may be that stuff you've read on the
internet or maybe the television show
that you watch or maybe the sports team
that you idolize,
read maybe some new invention somewhere
or some area or your huge belief into
some particular subset of what we know
or we don't know.
And to me that's all right.
Everybody should be doing that.
So long as they're pushing themselves to
something that they're interested in.
They're trying to get the best out of
the things that they're naturally
inclined towards and,
and make the most of it.
It's just been what I've been doing.
I'm just interested in this particular
part of space flight and a and m case,
or was fine by me live and let live,
but don't spend all of those efforts in
taking your particular set of interests
and your beliefs that,
that have given you this area and trying
to force them on other people.
Make them good for you.
Offering them up for other people to
believe if they like,
but then,
uh,
but don't,
don't try.
And convince everybody else in the world
that they're a Ufo is just because this
is what you believe.
Don't.
Why would that become your,
your,
uh,
your mantra?
Why would it be so important?
I think it's just like people that want
people to convert to Islam,
they just have this idea in their head
that this is the truth and they have to
pursue it.
It's just like a religion.
I think that the religion of belief,
you know,
the,
the intensity of ideology.
Once you know there's,
I know people that want you to be on a t
and t because that's their network know
like,
man,
I want you to do with verizon and at and
t there's a weird clan thing that human
beings have and blackberry versus ipad
and the people that believe in aliens,
they all stick together.
They go and they have conferences and it
becomes a part of their culture.
It's fun and there's this thing that
happens,
this confirmation bias where they don't
want to look at anything outside of
something that confirmed their idea.
They don't want to look at it
objectively.
I think having a belief system is
important.
Did you see anything up there?
Anything Weird?
No lights
world is really weird to look at this.
It's fascinating to look at in the
storms around the planet and the,
and the uh,
I was out on a spacewalk going through
the southern lights,
you know,
with the,
with the Aurora,
this case,
Aurora Australis coming up underneath my
feet for a thousand miles and that is a
weird thing to see.
It's beautiful.
It's fascinating.
It's,
it doesn't green real it.
Mostly what you see in pictures is green
because that's what the cameras see,
but in reality it's,
it's got red and orange and yellow
coming out the top of it so that your
eyes can pick up and it's,
it's a,
you can't believe it's real.
Like how could this possibly be earth?
How can this be going on all the time?
It's,
it is phenomenal to see,
especially when you can see for several
thousand miles and it's under your feet.
It's a,
it's amazing to see.
So yeah,
we see amazing stuff all the time.
Yeah.
That's way cooler than some dork in a
flying saucer.
It doesn't even have.
He doesn't even have the manners to come
and say hi.
He's got a circle around and abducted
you and erase your memory.
Me,
the world is is fascinating and unknown
and interesting enough with helping to
invent little green men visiting
it.
It really is,
and it.
It is.
The awareness of how fascinating truly
is is greatly enhanced by people like
you.
So I want.
Thank you very much.
Thank you very much for doing this.
Thank you very much for being you.
Thank you very much for writing this
book and astronaut's guide to life on
earth.
What going to space taught me about
ingenuity,
determination,
and being prepared for anything.
Colonel Chris Hadfield.
You Sir are bad.
Motherfucker was really nice.
Thank you very much.
This was very enjoyable and fascinating
conversation.
I really,
really appreciate it.
So folks,
go out and buy this book.
Is it available everywhere?
Can they get it on Amazon
available?
It's a New York Times best seller on
Amazon.
Go to Chris Hadfield.ca.
We'll show you everywhere you can buy
it.
Go Buy it,
folks,
support it,
and thanks to our sponsors,
thanks to squarespace.com,
use the code word Joe and the number 11.
All one word.
Save yourself 10 percent and thanks to
[inaudible] dot com.
That's o n n I t use the code name
Brogan and save 10 percent off any and
all supplements will be back later this
afternoon.
And we've got podcasts going on all
week.
Thank you everybody.
Makes sure you go out and buy this book.
Support,
support.
We love you guys.
Thank you.
Bye.
Hmm.